ce matin là coulombe a enfilé gants et
gilet jaune pour nettoyer sa commune une
bouteille pour les mégots on a un sac
pour m le plastique
on a une bouteille en verre aussi j'en
effectuera un second tri à l'issue de la
balade
comme elle ils sont 77 relevé de bon
matin pour participer c'est la deuxième
année que se déroule ce coran nettoyage
différents groupes ont été constitués et
chaque groupe fait en fait un itinéraire
très précis qui a été tracée au stabilo
durant deux heures ils sillonnent la
ville et traquent le moindre déchet ce
prêt des banques on trouve la plupart
des mégots et à chaque fois on remplit
quasiment une bouteille entière
donc ils focalisent l'attention sur les
parcs
j'ai pas toutes les citer mais voilà il
ya quand même plusieurs associations que
les siennes qui se sont joints à nous il
faut savoir que c'est un événement qui
est international qui a une déclinaison
française et qui voit là que donc du
coup on s'inscrit aussi dans quelque
chose d'assez globale au bout du périple
les équipes se retrouvent et mettre en
commun leurs récoltes fier du travail
accompli
je fais très attention parce que je suis
je suis déjà éco délégués au lycée au
lycée sonia-delaunay qui a à villepreux
et et non c'est quelque chose qui me
tient qui me tient à coeur
on fait plein de projets et puis c'est
vrai que voilà l'écologie c'est vraiment
un problème majeur dans notre dans les
sociétés au total en deux heures 173 kg
de déchets ont été ramassées aux
clayes-sous-bois dont 5,8 de mégots de
cigarettes